do you even like
have anyone who's critique you like or
like like who even has the power to tell
you like yeah this one ain't gonna take
it off like are you give do you give a
[ __ ] like if whether it's gun or m or
somebody who everybody
if i respect them and they like appear
in my craft you know what i'm saying
they give you input you're open to that
right you know if i'm a pilot and i fly
planes for a living like
somebody that just took a flight here
and there can't tell me how i should
have landed the flight you know what i'm
saying but like
it's just another pilot that flies too
and been flying longer than me or
whatever like
i take i i ain't one of those type of
dudes i'm open at criticism you know so
like the skis would be like yeah no i
think you could have said that last line
a little harder
little illa that you could have ended
that better i could have
you know we we've done that yes and
benny when we cook and stuff together
you know
we tell each other like nah bro say that
low say that last part a little better
you know what i'm saying oh i i i you
talking about that last night all right
i got you
yeah i said was that a west side
impersonation okay that's to tell me
like
i love this impersonation
oh you go a little crazier